a long-standing invitation is finally
accepted as dialog with a new ally could
pave the way forward for better
relations what's in store for the week
ahead it's time to find out welcome to
the agenda can David Cameron get the
backing he needs for proposal to
renegotiate the UK's EU membership the
British prime minister has finally
agreed to speak at the Parliament to set
up his plans for how the UK could stay
in the EU his visit comes ahead of a key
EU summit on the 18th and 19th of this
month but it won't be before a full
house he will attend the conference of
presidents and meeting behind closed
doors of the 8th parliamentary group
leaders find out how about meeting plays
out on Tuesday a nuclear deal with Iran
set a new course for international
relations but is the deal sustainable a
month before the deal was penned a
delegation from Parliament's Foreign
Affairs Committee traveled to around to
hold meetings with Iranian officials an
indication that he you institutions were
on board with a new era of cooperation
iran's Foreign Affairs Minister Mohammad
Javad Zarif returns gesture as he
attends a Foreign Affairs Committee
meeting on Tuesday he said he will not
hesitate to act if the inflation outlook
weakens so what will the President of
the European Central Bank tell any peace
the impact of China's economic slowdown
has reverberated worldwide the financial
markets finding Mario Draghi says that
European Central Bank will adapt to the
changing situation so kitty step in to
stop year's decline bike
spending monetary stimulus find out what
he has in store when he attends a
meeting of the economic and Monetary
Affairs Committee on Monday and now for
some news in brief parliamentarians from
across national parliaments earned
fainted over two days to debate best
practices for the economy over to the
Environment Committee where
representatives of the World Health
Organization will discuss the latest on
the Zika virus outbreak and also look
out for Europe our TV interview with the
MEP Roberta Gualtieri on Monday
where he'll discussed the banking union
annual report veterinary medicines are
set to be given an overhaul to better
protect against the harmful effects of
their traces are found in foodstuff
antibiotics have been targeted with
clearer definitions and marketing rules
been proposed in member states the aim
is also to widen the availability of
medicines to veterinarians and to
encourage research the Environment
Committee votes on the proposal on
Wednesday and that's all we have this
agenda take care and enjoy the week